[Music]
in YouTube dye new to DIY news oh I know
submitted by goo moussaka come on Sokka
Justino filipok so so i camasta boris
ICOMOS taka taka a car mechanic built
his own plane by watching videos on
YouTube that is beautiful I know I bet
you this [ __ ] is Asian what made
you think you is agent because when I
first started doing YouTube I made a
joke about this and it turns out to be
true nice also you know about this bar
in the this is UCLA video it's not
quoted as I put on t-shirts but I was
basically saying like okay next people
do anything like we can literally take
[ __ ] and turn it into an airplane okay
so it was like a Corolla that turned
into an airplane no it's just a lot of
recycled heart fresh in Latin America
I'd support Oh Rica they can do whatever
tobin's of Puerto Ricans make everything
work they can just make something if you
remember anywhere to get a car and then
they would make the car float so that
they can escape their country remember
they were to get a car and then they
would make the car float so that they
can escape their country
[Music]
I've been seeing photos lately of Cubana
because they're opening up tourism for
like now finally but like if you look at
the Cubana now it looks like 1950s
because other cars is old yeah they're
saying that you got to visit Cuba now
because they're starting to change it
and it's going to wipe out the whole 50s
look doll they should leave it like that
Cubans don't wanna live like that
anymore no obviously like still keep the
architectural integrity of like Europe
you're absolutely here they have like
the architectural integrity but they
used advanced technology around it but
cars do that adds to the whole 50 I want
to go to Cuba oh I'm down do you let me
pop this child out and I'm ready now
yeah I can just push their belly button
please no I'd be tight if it was just
here and they just magically appear like
all the molecules just like escape and
then it does I don't want to feel
anything happens with me you know you do
realize though you're losing the fact
that you get to shut that [ __ ] in your
kids [ __ ] face when they're older
which cool now is when we argue and I'm
saying something and then he tries to
throw in what it's mine to or whatever
like you didn't do [ __ ] I'm doing all
the work I did all the work literally
you know what I had to pause right I
[Laughter]
could have sworn I was on top doing all
the work you sound like our dogs buddy
throw up so this good he's a car
mechanic and so his name is pan long I'm
just calling mr. long so I'm not sure
how's his first name book genius yeah so
he's saying that since so he lives in
the rural part of Cambodia at kosowski
Cambodia and he said that when he was
six years old he saw a helicopter for
the first time and since then he's been
obsessed with like airplanes or aircraft
and so he was always determined to own a
plane someday so then he ended up
dropping out of school early and he
became a mechanic which is one of the
few jobs that you can you can get in
Cambodia without like a high school
diploma or anything that's not farming
and so he ended up
doing that for a while he saved up money
finally he was able to save enough money
to start this project and it took him
about three years he said that he would
be watching YouTube videos and then he
was really embarrassed of this project
so he would work on it at night like
when his wife was asleep when everyone's
asleep but he wouldn't tell anyone what
are they hi to airplane yeah I want to
know maybe it like a secret little
hiding place in the jungle wc2
chosen on a jungle and forest theme all
day intonation he's like a Cambodian
like right rudder but just one so he
thought that it would be too complicated
to make a helicopter so he thought
making a small if one cedar airplane
would be a lot easier so he modeled his
airplane after a design from the
Japanese airplane that was used in World
War two a kamikaze plane and all those
claims I used to like crash into like
American ships okay the pilot seat is a
plastic chair with the legs caught off
the control panel is a card dashboard
the body is made of an old gas container
I look like one of you ever rode in a
plane before
you've never roll in a plane before or
in any aircraft he has never been in he
was just always obsessed with it that
looks [ __ ] good
that's weakened oh dude I was expecting
something way more but Lee is acting
operational back in March he did his I
can put this plane to test are we scared
dude I never flew before and it's the
first time with no co-pilot like nope
just you might die oh hell he's so
determined and IKEA has like this tunnel
vision where it's like I'm making this a
reality
how about just six oh yes I'm saying
that that babe I can work that he had
like all of like his neighbors like all
the villagers the villagers saying that
there were about 200 to 300 people that
were there to speculate but Mr long
generously estimates the size of the
crowd to be about 2,000 people oh [ __ ]
he's turning all the animals in the
trees that I saw 200 by I think 2000 if
you count my ancestor in the spirits
that came that claim looks [ __ ] legit
I'm gonna get it to the like runway did
he get busy yeah it was gonna kiss
Oakland he had three people help him
push it onto his runway which is just a
nearby dirt road leading onto like the
main road of that town and so finally
got on the runway he his only safety
precaution was a motorcycle helmet
that's all he had does that help you
falling out of a plane to get out on
your head again
they had no parachute not even like
three umbrellas just in case all your
buddies leaving Germans love look at
this what your breath isn't even helium
hahahahaha
just trying his best oh yeah so he has
up taking off he said that he got he
actually got into the air and he got up
about 50 meters up in the air which was
165 feet that's pretty high up where and
then he ended up Chris
if you okay they don't mention that he
got injured yes I was just going to try
again I mean yeah obviously he is okay
he didn't die or anything but I don't
know he had any injuries I would [ __ ]
stop right there [ __ ] oh you are he's so
determined I would that will stop I'm
saying no you wouldn't know he's saying
that once he like crashed on the ground
that he immediately heard the sound of
laughter creating him to the flooring so
he says quote I was standing there and
tears came down my cheeks I felt
emotional because I couldn't bear all
the things they were saying to me she
made me look like a fool especially
there's 2,000 people fine I was
embarrassed that's [ __ ] up he built a
plane with his bare hand people are
crying like I'm not fine they're
simpletons they can under all the
complexities and so now he's saying that
this setback made him even more
determined to succeed and so now he has
turned his attention to a new project no
spaceship [ __ ] bugs it's a deadly
weapon to your killer when our last
better no he still wants to fly so he's
focused on a seaplane now what he should
build is a [ __ ] dairy and shooter
it's a blast all the people that [ __ ]
laugh out of that
but it's funny though he's wanting to
build a seaplane when he's 125 miles
away from the nearest ocean that's how
the Herman is he's smart and not so
smart [ __ ] gangster he also spent
like ten thousand dollars on that
airplane make all that money he had Ava
was ten thousand oh my say so his wife
is like you know she's worried for his
safety so she was telling him like you
please stop like I'm scared you're gonna
die we have two young kids like please
don't do this and by the way to sidenote
his wife sells I'm chill no huh [ __ ]
that's why I talk about long way watch
me pee shells music hard part seller so
this is right note but anyways so if
she's saying like you know I really want
him to stop but he's so determined that
I'm just going to support him so what a
down-ass woman yeah this is his wife
she's not a dream crusher dick are you
gonna say no I wasn't gonna say that
just says you've got a jeep crusher so
now he's like you know what I am I even
though like I don't I don't really know
much about seaplanes I'm going to learn
and I'm gonna make this a successful
story I want to ride in a seaplane I
never wrote in a seaplane before about a
helicopter I never roll in a helicopter
either saying that he spent already
three thousand dollars on this seat
please Oh reports the saying like dude
you could afford like a really nice
vacation for his family instead of doing
this like now why would you want to
[ __ ] relax obviously it makes him
happy it's not like vacation vacation is
relative you know I mean it's going on
vacation to make him happy doesn't
[ __ ] matter what he goes well you're
saying that he doesn't pay for anything
but just his hobby you saying that in
reference to the whole vacation thing
doesn't care about it so far it's
probably done in small increments where
it's like you know and I think it's like
the added cost yes technically he could
but obviously the wife supports him if
it makes him happy and he's still
providing so at the end of the day he's
doing what he has to do and he's also
filling his fuel to his own fire so I
completely supports you when you crash
your plane again hello everybody
if you liked the video make sure that
you guys leave us a thumbs up because if
not I'm gonna find you where you live
and I'm going to hug the [ __ ] out of you
what do you not other than that you know
there's like more videos up there Brown
[Music]